so what I've said so far doesn't
guarantee anything about the existence
of limit where Newton's Conant is
actually Infinity but nevertheless that
limit may exist if that limit exists
that limit the limiting theory is a
theory in 11 Dimensions it'll be a super
symmetric realistic theory in 11
Dimensions with 11 dimensional superg
gravity as its low energy limit and
depending on no dimensionless parameters
does it exist I haven't the faintest
idea all I'm saying is that while in the
past I would have bet against it I shall
place no such bet
[Music]
today welcome back to science click
today M
Theory at present we can describe our
universe with two main theories general
relativity Which models gravity on a
large scale through a curved
SpaceTime and the standard model of
particles which unifies all other
interactions using Quantum Fields whose
vibrations can be interpreted as
particles in essence these two models
are quite similar both make use of the
concept of fields the field of curvature
of SpaceTime for general relativity and
the quantum fields of particles for the
standard
model but while relativity is a
classical Theory it predicts a precise
Evolution over time the standard model
is quantum its description consists of
superpositions and
probabilities hence these two theories
describe two completely different
worlds at a large scale general
relativity is an excellent description
of our universe however when we zoom
into mattera we have to consider the
phenomena of quantum
physics for now this is not a problem
we can describe the disturbances of the
curvature of SpaceTime as a Quantum
field whose fluctuations we interpret as
particles
gravitons we thus determine the quantum
behavior of
gravity however zooming in further to
ridiculously small scales down to a
quintilian of a micrometer smaller than
the plank length the calculations no
longer work at this fundamental scale
gravity seems incompatible with the
Quantum
world how then to reconcile them how to
understand what happens where gravity
acts at a fundamental scale such as at
the center of black holes or during the
first moments of the Big Bang in this
video we are going to immerse ourselves
in the abstract world of theoretical
physics in search of a promising
framework to solve this problem beware
this subject is particularly abstract
and it is recommended to have first
watched our String Theory video
[Music]
video we are in the 1970s and
researchers are interested in a
promising Theory superg
gravity our SpaceTime has four
symmetries the laws of physics remain
the same after translations rotations
the passing of time and changes a frame
of
reference these four symmetries are
mathematically included within general
relativity but there might exist another
still hypothetical symmetry called super
symmetry if we also consider this
symmetry we get super
gravity in essence supergravity is very
similar to relativity SpaceTime can bend
generate interesting structures and even
produce singularities without Dimension
forming black
holes
physicists also explore supergravity in
hypothetical universes with additional
dimensions and the theory then leads to
generalizations of black holes with one
two or more Dimensions which form
extended objects membranes or brains for
short these can have a mass a charge and
even be super
symmetric this model is interesting but
once we zoom in beyond the plank scale
the theory still breaks down as with
relativity supergravity fails at the
fundamental
[Music]
scale a few years later in the 1980s
physicist discovered a revolutionary new
model which assumes that all particles
are made up of a small strand of
vibrating energy a
string as it also exploits the concept
of super symmetry we call it super
String
Theory when they meet strings can
interact with each other merge or divide
and like a guitar string they have
different modes of vibration which
behave at our scale like different
particles with amazement we discover
that one of these modes of vibration
behaves exactly like the gravit
for the first time a theory allows us to
describe quantum gravity in a
fundamental
way the model is promising but it set
several restrictions on the
universe the theory imposes that
SpaceTime has not four but 10 Dimensions
with six additional spatial Dimensions
that we have not yet
detected the theory also sets the type
of strings that can be studied if we
decide decide to study open strings for
example little strands these can curl up
on themselves and we must therefore also
study closed strings little
Loops taking these restrictions into
account researchers found that super
String Theory only allows for five
possible universes type one which
contains both open and closed strings
types 2 a and 2B which contain Clos
strings and two heterotic types s so32
and E8 cross E8 which contain closed
strings with different types of
vibrations that move in opposite
directions these five models are the
only possible variations allowed if we
hope to describe our universe with super
strings so which of these five versions
do we live in which truly describes our
universe let's leave this question aside
for now and return to superg
gravity
[Music]
at this point one might think that super
string theory and super gravity are two
entirely independent models however
there is in fact an intimate connection
between the two on a large scale both
describe a super symmetric Universe with
gravity in fact supergravity when
applied to a universe with 10 Dimensions
turns out to be an approximation of
super String
Theory this implies in particular that
the brains of supergravity also exist in
the world of super
strings strings are precisely one of the
many possible brains with one dimension
but there are also D brains which open
strings can end
on or even ns5 brains with five
Dimensions the model of super gravity
therefore remains useful ful and
researchers become interested in another
unexpected property superg gravity only
accepts a maximum of 11 Dimensions one
more than in super string
theory in this 11-dimensional
supergravity model all the constants of
the universe would be fixed by
mathematics unlike with the five
possible choices of super strength
theories supergravity proposes a new
Standalone Theory to describe the world
at least as an approximation with 11
[Music]
Dimensions by the early 1990s we have a
panel of six interesting mathematical
models the five versions of super String
Theory with 10 dimensions and the 11
dimensional super
gravity on top of this several
researchers and in particular Edward
witon gradually discover a network of
subtle connections dualities which
relate all these theories to each
other physicists Begin by looking at
11-dimensional
supergravity amongst many other things
this model contains brains with two
Dimensions imagine now that we transform
one of the 11 Dimensions into a circle
and reduce it until it is no longer
visible after this compactification only
10 dimensions are left and the brains
have lost one dimension becoming
strings in a surprising way the
resulting model behaves like super
strength Theory or more precisely like
its 2A
version before discovering this Duality
researchers could only study strings
which interact weakly with each other
indeed the method used to calculate
their behavior known as the perturbative
approach consists in taking a first
estimate and adding small corrections to
integrate interactions more and more
precisely if the strings interact
strongly however these Corrections
become too large they cannot refine the
result and even an infinite number of
them would not allow us to describe
certain
phenomena discovering the link between
these two theories however will allow
scientists to probe the behavior of
strongly interacting strings
to do this we just need to regrow the
11th Dimension that we had compactified
into a circle by adding this Dimension
we describe the universe of the 2A
Theory but this time for strongly
interacting
strings to model this regime we need an
11th
Dimension similarly we can compactify
the 11th Dimension into a line segment
rather than a circle this time we obtain
a description of the E8 cross E8 Theory
and again the link between the two
models allows physicist to probe the
behavior of strongly interacting strings
for which the calculations weren't
possible
before little by little researchers
discover other
dualities for instance taking the 2A and
2B theories and compactifying each of
them on a circle one large the other
small we obtain two models that describe
the same universe in two different ways
each quantity in one is related to
another quantity in the other for
instance the speed of a string moving in
the compact Dimension is related to the
number of times it wraps around that
dimension in the other
description this is called T Duality it
also connects the two heterotic theories
together as a final example we also
discover s Duality when strings interact
strongly on one side and weakly on the
other we already saw two examples of
this with 11-dimensional
supergravity which allows us to model
strongly interacting strings within two
of the super string
theories this duality in fact also
applies to the types 1 and
so32 or more interestingly to the 2B
Theory with
itself when we invert the strength of
the interactions the types of brains
contained within the theory convert back
into each other such that we recover the
original
model in just a few years researchers
discover many dualities which connect
all of these theories to each
other thanks to these dualities we can
transform tedious calculations in one
model into simpler calculations in
another these discoveries have allowed
us to study phenomena previously
inaccessible and to discover for example
that the entropy of black holes the
amount of information that they contain
can be calculated by counting the
strings which are attached to them the
results are in perfect agreement with
Hawking's radiation
formulas this gush of research also led
to the discovery of the ads CFT
correspondence According to which
certain universes can be described Des
cribed as Holograms of their
[Music]
surface in 1995 Witten proposed that
there could be a single fundamental
theory of which the five versions of
super strings and 11 dimensional superg
gravity would only be
approximations a bit like half-drawn
maps of an unknown landscape these Six
Theories could be partial description
ions and the dualities which connect
them could indicate that they overlap in
places to describe the same
zones Witten called this model M
Theory a mysterious name for an equally
mysterious
Theory perhaps standing for membrane or
Matrix he leaves the freedom to Future
researchers who will understand it
better to decide its
meaning at large scales considering we
interactions M Theory would describe an
11-dimensional super symmetric World
containing brains but at the fundamental
level although everything seems to
indicate that it exists its formalism
remains a mystery it could turn out to
be a completely new description of the
universe there are already attempts such
as the bfss matrix model According to
which SpaceTime and strings would emerge
from a purely abstract description but
research in this area is proving very
complex at present as with all other
theories that attempt to unify gravity
and the quantum World M Theory is not
supported by any experimental
evidence like other theories it allows
for a wide variety of initial
configurations with different contents
and geometries of SpaceTime and we don't
yet know which one corresponds to our
universe just as we cannot probe the
geometry of our SpaceTime at a very
large scale we cannot probe it on a
fundamental scale either at least for
now it stands however as the most
advanced candidate in the search for a
Theory of Everything unifying gravity
and the standard model for many
researchers it is an elegant and
promising Theory which predicts gravity
without having to add it to the
model research around M Theory has
opened many doors in both physics and
Mathematics in parallel many other other
theories have been developed such as
Loop quantum gravity causal dynamical
triangulation or asymptotic safety which
also attempt to unify gravity and the
quantum
World which of these models will allow
us to understand the foundations of our
universe who knows they may in fact
complement each other leading to an
integrated framework of an even more
general
theory
[Music]